the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right we've got we've got some good
competition here so let's let's actually
work through it okay so I'm I have a
function called always sunny and it's
going to take into two variables right
t1 and t2 and I'm calling it with cloudy
and cold okay so when I do my function
call t1 is going to be equal to cloudy
these are strings but I'm not going to
bother putting the quotes and t2 is
equal to cold comma okay so remember
what I said with a comma it's a tuple
without a comma it's a string so t1 is
actually going to be a string and t2 is
actually a tuple okay so that's the
first sort of trick to this question so
I've made my function call and I've
assigned t1 and t2 to be those those two
values so the next line is Sun is equal
to sunny comma Sun so Sun is going to be
this tuple of two strings the next line
is figuring out what first is so first
is going to be so I'm looking at my t1
here it's a string right the fact that I
have parentheses doesn't actually make a
difference when I'm talking about
strings like that so when I'm indexing
into a string t1 at position 0 actually
just gives me a C because it's a string
not a tuple
and t2 up position zero says okay well
this is a tuple that contains only one
element that element being at position
zero and that element is this string
cold right so this is a tuple so I'm
taking everything right before the first
comma and that happens to be just the
one element that's in there okay so this
is just the string C cold and then I'm
returning here a tuple and the tuple I'm
returning is Sun at position zero so
that's just sunny comma just doing what
is what's in here and then first and
first was this string C cold okay so
really the important thing about this
example was to make sure that you
understand the difference between what a
string is and what a tuple is okay